blessé lors de la 3
oui
bonsoir long laure de lattre lors de la
pesée 25 ans vous êtes né à paris-xii
les yeux marrons les cheveux bruns et
vous êtes vous mesurez un mètre soixante
une et des patates et les patates vous
posez 42 kg signe particulier vous avez
un piercing sur la langue et au nombril
et retenu ans et oui votre pensée de là
tu ne vais rien à voir avec le maréchal
de lattre de tassigny votre prénom c'est
lors votre surnom celle à bourges où la
peste et votre titre de gloire c'est de
voir était deuxième finaliste a love
story
quelle morale nous tirer de loft story
c'était génial
c'était super les gens nous demandent
c'est c'était difficile
c'est pas difficile d'être coupés du
monde sans problème son souci du
lendemain sans problème d'argent
on a un petit problème dans la tête on
en parle aussi on a un petit problème
matériel
on en parle à la preuve très bien ça
vous choque pas que des gens deviennent
ces lettres sans rien faire juste en
restant enfermé à la plaine saint denis
dans un mobilier ikea choquant non
étonnant oui et génial super à vivre ce
une opportunité à saisir et les gens qui
disent ouais elle fait ça elle a rien
fait avant mais eux ils profiteraient
aussi de cette opportunité rien après
mais les gens
ne vous mettez le sur les bras
écoutez je vous demande pas donc hommage
et moi je suis pas au courant
vous pourriez père où j'ai pas dans ça
s'est passé très vite est magnifique
mais bon j'en ai entendu parler mais
mais bravo bon ben voilà il faut que ça
continue on va tous faire courant vous
soyez heureusement je suis heureux j'ai
rencontré un garçon mais oui un oui mais
il est génial c'est le mieux pour en
parler
non mais je me trouvais c'est un bon
exemple sérieusement à donner aux
générations futures de voir des gens de
venir c'est d'être simplement rester
enfermé je pourrais 78 exemple à donner
c'est qu'il faut foncer il ya quelque
chose qui se présentent
faut pas dire ans je le fais je le fais
pas qu'est ce que ça va donner après au
fond ce nom pas rien fait enfin je veux
dire on a fait très beau c'est un
exercice non ils ont ils avaient des
exercices imposés c'est ça vous aurait
été enregistrée par la production
c'était faire de la poterie à vouziers
ouais je sais pas non mais c'est pas
vrai ça vous inquiète les dérives de la
trash télé aujourd'hui en france je
pense pas qu'il en ait en france ça
quand même été très soft le lob
finalement tous arrivent en bus